instead of a doubleheader yesterday we
have a doubleheader today jose arena on
the mound for the tigers has not won
since may 21st quickly head 1-0
broken back grounder no problem for
jonathan scope
here's the payoff to him
on the ground to third
candelario deep behind the bag no
problem now the one two to lark to
center field on a line derek hill is
there and that's a good start for jose
arena 13 pitches in
charlie barnes making his major debut
out here he's
going to face the detroit tigers hitter
see robbie grossman is the perfect lead
off hitter because you know he's going
to watch some pitches here here's the
2-2
fly ball deep left center field
that's going to find the alley over the
wall
robbie grossman with a leadoff bomb
the career-high numbers continue it
climbs to 13 and it's one nothing tigers
what a lead up hitter
[Applause]
in the hole through the left side for a
base hit for jonathan scope
ground ball off the glove
of barnes
he retires cabrera but it does allow
scope to move up to second there are two
away
that's down the right field line chased
by larnick and he's got it in foul
territory well charlie barnes isn't the
first pitcher to give up a home run to
his first hitter
over the gold
iranian strikes out nelson cruz to start
the
second on the ground to first off the
glove of jonathan scope
and kirloff is aboard
with one away
it kind of comes up and handcuffs him
there's the first twins hit
and kiraloff will pull in at second base
the 3-2
on the ground gloved by zack short
nice play and they retire kepler at
first
and jonathan scope looks injured and
then i like he knows he's only got one
so what does he do gets around
takes his time and makes a good throw
well there's what happened yeah kepler's
left knee
colliding with jonathan scope's right
elbow he's going to stay in good good
the 1-2 and he foul tipped it into the
glove of jake rogers problem avoided
and the 1-2 and swing and a miss and
down goes
zach short on a change up
and there is the first big league
strikeout for charlie burns
good movement to that ball fading away
sharply hit backhanded by short wow and
scope can't handle it and we'll guess
that a rise will get a base hit
2-2 on the ground zach short
flips to paredes to double play turn
that's the way you get out of it jose
arena dialed in early through three you
saw norris warming up in the tiger pen
arena
with the hoodie on
slap hard
from the third baseman over to the
shortstop and they got him donaldson
with the carom to simmons and then
simmons airing out the throw
and it's a one two three third inning
something that may have irked jose arena
enough to bring in daniel norrish
scope leads norris to the bag and
there's one away the 2-0
cruise
to right field
over his grossman then he puts it away
[Applause]
on the ground to zach short daniel
norris comes in picks up right where
jose arena left off a one two three
fourth good start for charlie barnes
after the poor star the first at bat
robbie grossman hit one over the fence
but he's been really good throwing
strikes barnes has set down nine men in
a row
starting with haas hitting a fly ball to
center in the first inning he's done a
good job of pitching in and out
and that's off of donaldson and this
time simmons can't get the carrum and
throw the runner out
[Applause]
he had some top spin on it
just missed it i think that'll go down
on his air as an error i think it had so
much top spin it kind of kicked on that
second hop coming out of that
deep to the right field corner
well actually more to straight away
right field larnick with the catch on
the first out
and there's a liner to polanco for route
number two
a lot of tension on it
is with a base hit to left
[Applause]
left center field looks like kepler's
under it
to end the inning and barnes pitches
around the lead off error in the fourth
it's still one-nothing detroit
they did it well
there's daniel norris's first strikeout
of the day
two outs in the minnesota fifth
probably breaking out of the zone but
well disguised by daniel norris
he gets caught looking looking for that
breaking ball built back-to-back
strikeouts for daniel norris the twins
go in order jake rogers
derek hill and robbie grossman for the
tigers here in the field
rogers down the right field line and
that is a fair ball into the corner
rogers will hustle for second he's got
himself a stand-up double to start the
tigers fifth
he just previously bet shot one foul
and now this one's inside he was a pull
pull pull mode now he's using the field
so
it just tells me he's buying in
four pitch free pass
[Applause]
softly to polanco they get an out there
now the runner between second and third
i don't know whether the ball was caught
on the fly it's a double play
i believe and now rocco going to come
out and nice job by charlie barnes in
his major league debut
2-1
off the end of the bat
into center field that drops in front of
kepler who bobbles it grossman will hold
at third base
well this one will be a fair ball
retreating as simmons back paddling and
ends the inning
the one two
wave and a miss and funkhouser's day
starts with a strikeout of anderton
simmons now the 2-2
he got him
[Applause]
they'll throw him out at first base but
kyle funkhouser strikes out the first
two batters he faces
funkhouser strikes out the side pumped
up
cabrera will lead off the sixth against
burroughs
first ball
donaldson picks it up has time to
recover and throw cabrera out so it
hasn't been the best day for donaldson
in the field or at the plate but he
makes a fine play there for round number
one
candelario rips one to right
that sounded it must have felt great
strike three is called burroughs pitches
a scoreless six gregory soto the
all-star is in in a wall side windows
pitching change and he has been good in
seven of the eight save situations for
the tigers
fly ball left side long run for
candelario he catches up to it and puts
it away
sharply to short
zach shorts smothers it and there are
two away in the seventh
on the ground to first scope will take
it himself that's a nice win for the
tigers in their first game back after
the all-star break